all right we're live all right hello
guys we've got an exciting two-part
announcement for you guys today we're
doing a hackathon
and
it's like one person watching maybe we
should wait a second
but sure we'll just we can quickly go to
our metrics dashboard in the meantime hi
everybody
so some of our exciting metrics in the
meantime
we got some announcements in a minute
this is our metrics dashboard
this is what we try to improve on every
time
we talk often about uh how bank turns
the car cuts cuts corners on lanes you
can see that over here you wanna show
how the lines are gonna go harold uh
yeah so you see these distributions
that's where it drives in left and right
turns and because it's cutting they're
not matching so we want to get them you
know
together
so that's what the vac is working on and
the lanes will be better
what else is interesting on the metrics
dashboard
do we have like
do you want to show lunch
yeah let's show lunch
[Laughter]
this is our lunch here's what we had
today check out the menu here
it was pretty interesting
yeah i know it's pretty good we got some
some kind of uh thai curry yeah weird
kiwis
they're so bizarre that's not the live
color that they look like that in real
life too it's pretty it's pretty
shocking
um
are you ready for the announcements
again
yeah let's do it yeah so the big
announcement is we're doing a hackathon
and we spin it around because the mic is
hello guys
we're doing a hackathon it's going to be
uh november what is it 13th
12th 12th and 13th
yes 12th 13th and 14th and to get into
the hackathon we made a capture the flag
challenge which uh you guys can find
some flags and then you'll be able to
get into the hackathon and we'll
make the instructions for the ctf for
the capture the flag live right now and
we'll go to a deep and we'll follow him
as we uh
as we publish the instructions let's do
it
so the hackathon's gonna you know we're
gonna learn a lot about open pilots it's
gonna be a fun hangout there'll be some
prizes
all the fun stuff
all right
look at all the code work going on here
deeb's a
mastermind you open that up right before
the screen with you
never seen it look like this so it's the
weekend
it's gonna start friday night
on the 12th
yeah and then we'll uh we'll do the
full-on competition uh the 13th and the
14th
the friday evening on the 12th will just
be a little bit of a hangout
food
included um and who i think the most
exciting thing about the hackathon is
whoever um
captures all the flags first we will
cover your flight and accommodations to
come to the hackathon domestic yeah
oh look at that the instructions are
live
live on the open pilot repo give us a
little
tell us a little bit about the ctf what
inspired you all right what is it what
am i looking at
so we have one route for you it's a
seemingly normal open pilot route um
driving down beautiful san diego
and it's uh four segments long
so four minutes and there's two flags in
each minute of the route
and then each flag and each segment uh
roughly increases in difficulty
um everything you need to find the flags
is in the open pilot repo we've really
been pushing on tools lately
um deenly's done a great job of
rewriting um we had this old tool
on logger and uh
dean lee uh did a great job rewriting
this in c plus plus it's really fast now
sweet it's uh really stable hopefully
we'll get that on the device soon so you
can do uh on device replays like you
could in open pilot like zero three
we'll bring that back
oh look at that yeah so uh this is super
legit
the the time starts now guys
first guy to get all the all the flags
we'll get fully comped and make sure
fights and accommodation make sure
you're a winner
you want to be a winner that's for sure
yeah so uh don't wait
yeah so
i mean it's a pretty big deal hackathon
prizes will include a comma three cross
country edition which is a 27.99 value
wow that's a pretty good prize
in there
we'll throw in a harness too okay just
checking yeah yeah no worries you will
be taken care of if you're a winner
maybe you've got a commentary i feel
like you really got to put you know oh
yeah yeah be a winner be a winner it's
right there
yeah and of course be a winner do not
leak any flags or clues or you will be
shamed and uninvited
right don't make me uninvite you first
rule of ctf is not to talk about how to
do the ctf we'll do some honest
sportsmanship on this competition but
yeah so super exciting two competitions
at the same time released on the same
day it's it's been a while we've been
really working on it we put a lot of
effort into meeting this deadline
um it's been a lot a lot of distributed
work in uh making this competition come
together so yeah hope you guys enjoy it
we uh we all kind of thought it was
pretty fun testing it i think most like
half of the engineers here did the ctf
and we all had a pretty good time
um maybe we can go to my desk and we can
uh
we can just give a little teaser on how
you would get started on this uh
let's do it on this little route ctf
look at all these boxes we have they're
everywhere
thousands
we're officially entering
prices went up department i don't
remember that changing
change
all okay so uh
don't fill my
password
i'll show you this plant
okay
we're back all right so yeah so the
challenge is just gonna be a route and
you're just going to use regular open
pilot tools
to to find the flag so here's a normal
route that's not a ctf route and you can
use replay to replay that and once
you've got ompul installed it should
just be running that command with the
ctf route
so now that's running and then you can
run ui
and you'll just see uh the ui as it
would have popped up as you were driving
the route
and this is pretty much it this is all
you if you get this far and you've got
the ctf route in the replay this is all
you need and you'll
you'll
see all the information you need to
continue from there
yeah we've all tried it we all thought
it was really fun i think i think you
guys will enjoy it too
don't be discouraged if you experience
some issues trying to install it install
all the
tools that's always a bit of a challenge
but once you get past that it should all
be pretty fun and uh
there shouldn't be any any new
challenges along the way it should just
be a fun little competition
yeah that's cool
adeeb worked very hard for a few days
making this for you guys so
okay he deserves that how many flags are
there total there's eight eight flags
okay and this is just part one so i
think we'll do uh another part um soon
we have some more
uh difficult challenges that aren't
gonna be a qualifier for a hackathon
um that i think will just be fun maybe
we'll put on some prizes later on but uh
this part one is the qualifier for our
hackathon cool
yeah might do some more some more this
type of stuff for the hackathon
and we'll probably come up with some
list of kind of projects to guide you
guys uh to work on during the hackathon
the hackathon's also again going to be
centered around
interacting with open pilot tools and
getting openpower to run on your
computer and maybe doing some simulation
or kind of some quick development and
stuff like that so it should all be
pretty fun sure it'll be a fun hangout
and uh i think we'll learn a lot from it
so pretty excited
sweet
we have more things we want to talk
about should we put a bounty out for
first person submit a pr oh yeah
quickly uh yeah yeah so you can mention
that
all right so we'll put a put like 100
bounty out first person to submit a pr
that fixes some tool that's useful for
the ctf
um
will uh yeah first one that gets it
merged
um
they'll get uh
100 bucks yeah you want to pull up the
uh the blog post one more time we'll
just go through all the
all the details one more time
um and this pr does have to be good yes
we're not uh lowering the bar for pr
submissions for this uh pr challenge
that's right uh so yeah you have until
the 20th
and uh by the 22nd we'll have emailed
everybody who's invited to the hackathon
reminder it's in person in san diego
it's going to be at a
a secret location
and that's what it is november 12th to
14th
and yeah we have the ctf prizes right
here first prize again to get all the
flags you get domestic flight and
accommodations covered to attend comma
hack
or 250 and then second place a hundred
dollars third place merch
and uh yeah if you want to come a three
it's a good way to get one if you come
to the hackathon yeah exactly
comma three is too expensive just uh
come win one yes
so this is the form right here that
you're gonna use to to fill it out it's
right below
so this is on the blog it's also linked
in the video description right now so
you can check it out
any questions
yeah you can answer some questions if
anyone's got any can we give any hints
um if anyone asks that's a pretty good
this is a pretty good hint yeah if you
just do what i did on my computer run
replay run ui i think that'll get you
started pretty well well i think yeah
and then really make sure you read the
the read me
those uh those hints in there those tips
really take them to heart go read the
places it tells you to read read some
documentation play around with
replay a little bit get familiar with
the seeking interface um
actually i'll write some more
documentation on that today
but i think this will really help if you
seek around in the segments skip around
um
if you get stuck on a segment you know
try out the other ones
we tried to sort them by difficulty but
you know really depends
cool should be good fun yeah and a
reminder if if you're not a hacker type
uh in a week in a few days we're going
to be doing the video contest uh winners
as well so kama's just doing a lot right
now yeah kind of competition not just
flying out the door
oh man so so yeah you can check out the
last live stream if you want to know
about the video contest if you're not
like a hacker type but yeah the ctf is
really cool and uh any last questions
i didn't really see any questions to be
honest everyone's everyone knows what's
going on should we check discord for
questions
yeah let's let's check real quick
whether anyone's confused about anything
pop that up in the lobby and lobby your
announcement live stream is up
now's your chance
either post
in lobby or post uh right now
um
what's the flag
yeah so the capture the flag is just you
know they're they're little things
little little nuggets that you should
find in the route and uh
i mean that's basically a flag and
they're like little clues and and every
clue you found it counts as a flag
uh it's just this
type of competition that's pretty
popular in like programming it's called
capture the flag it's not something we
invented so if you want to find out more
about just capture the flags in general
just uh
google it and you'll you'll find plenty
of plenty of content yeah if you don't
know what it is
it's uh there's no prerequisites here as
long as you follow getting started in uh
the readme for the ctf then you should
be you'll get your first flag there's
your hint yeah i haven't i haven't done
any ctfs myself either so don't worry
about that and yeah you don't have to be
a hacker but you should know some stuff
about you know python um i think that
that might be a requirement
but you definitely don't have to be a
hacker or have experience with ctf to do
this
yeah that's a good reminder too someone
in
discord just brought up
uh will
are there any intern invites for winners
i mean
in the past
yeah in the past like that's how we hire
we hired vivec that way yeah we've yeah
it's definitely if you're interested in
in common working with us or just open
pilots definitely a good place to be
somebody said uh is this hackathon worth
it for beginners um yeah yeah i think
yeah we also partially wrote this as
like documentation for open pilot like
if you get through this etf then you're
gonna get familiar with all the open
pilot tools
um
either some
good
uh like the common tools we use um
pretty much on a day-to-day basis you're
pretty familiar with
so i think regardless of the hackathon
if you just want to learn more about
open file development um
this is a really good way to to get
started yeah the ctf is not in our irl
that's just something you do at home and
you send us the flags um and then the
hackathon which you can get into with
the ctf that's going to be in real life
in san diego location not decided yet
secret secrets
um well you know
if you like pizza red bull and to hang
out with a bunch of common engineers and
that was your chance to do the ctf and
it was pretty fun last time i think
it'll be fun again yeah if there's some
more questions can you do this on a mac
um yeah it should work it should work
i'll test it out later today but another
question is there a certain format for a
flag
flag yeah that'll be obvious the flag
formats are
they're all the same you'll see the
the first the first flag tells you what
they look like if you do what i did on
my computer just run the route and
replay run ui it'll be quite obvious uh
what's going on from there so yeah
um but yeah back to the mac thing um
max used to work a little bit we had to
turn off the ci for a while so i'll go
back and test edit but it should build
and most of the tools should run
but uh we'll go back and double check
that maybe you can fix the tools for mac
and it's your first pr you get 100 bucks
and if you fix some real issues 100 for
you yeah
um
cool news should we shout out the
calibration challenge too for interns
in general oh yeah if anyone's
interested in being hired for just uh
research
um or open pilot potentially i think but
it's more of a research appropriate
channel uh challenge you can go to uh
the calibration challenge let's check it
out
um so that's call my eye caleb challenge
and yeah that's that's basically our
hiring challenge for research um
you have to estimate the direction of
travel
of of of the camera through some video
so the video will be moving and you kind
of have to write an algorithm that
estimates which direction uh you're
moving in um it's quite difficult but
should be pretty fun
um this is our new version of the
challenge we used to do the speed
challenge but i think uh
state-of-the-art machine learning
techniques got a little bit too good and
you could just train very good models
just out of the box that solved the
speed challenge to a pretty good degree
so this is a new challenge that's kind
of meant to avoid that problem and you
do have to do things some things
yourself nothing out of the box i think
will really work
so i think it's a little bit more fun a
little bit more challenging
cool comma hack 2021 it's real any eta
on the fisheye for the coma three no
that doesn't sound ctf related we have
do you want to show them watch three
watch these beautiful yeah you want to
show them watch three let's check let's
let's let's do watch dude it's really
cool
um i mean yeah the we we are internally
we've been doing some things with uh
with the fisheye
um and and we'll see as soon as we can
get like good improvements on bigger
frames we do intend to ship that but
it's not something we want to do until
you know it has good good uh
i don't find where is watch three
oh i see
watch three
no you have to start it with uh replay
oh i said you can't flags
look at all these hints you guys are
getting here you're
i'm struggling with things that you you
might run into yourself
it's called watch three because there's
three cameras yeah nice
exactly and it's comma three that's true
oh you might not have all the cameras
uploaded just do dash demo
just dash no route yeah no right just
that just
okay
some somebody's already posting some
things so that's um
interesting let's be careful with those
posts yeah no more posts and more posts
like that
all right it's downloading that's good
inside it's doing something
and once this gets going it's really
fast dean lee did a great job it's a
huge shout out to deanly is the demo
route all right
oh there we go check it out oh this is
the new demo route yeah with mitchell
yeah
so he's also in this etf yeah this is a
cool uh cool tool isn't it guys wow look
at that tool look at that
oh awesome someone said i have class
right now i'm gonna go go gonna go
straight home and work on this yeah i i
thought it was really fun i hope you
guys enjoy it too i think once you go
through the installation process that
might be painful depending on some some
things you run into but i think after
that it's really just a fun challenge
and you'll learn a lot
um
i see so the uh
the clue has been deleted so that's good
that's good uh
yeah linux yeah linux ubuntu 2004 i
tried to get it running on ubuntu 16 and
that wasn't working so
try linux ubuntu
2004 if you have the choice
yep
cool any bounty for best pr in the tools
yeah so we mentioned that if you fix any
of the tools um you get a 100
uh
price
if you if you make any good pr to fix
any of that stuff
um yeah
cool what's uh wsl is that the world cup
no windows subsystem for linux so we
haven't tested this but uh quite a few
people in the community say uh version
two of the windows subsystem for linux
works pretty well even works with our
gui tools and they can load up the open
pilot ui i believe so
all these tools i believe should work
but um
and if you confirm that uh maybe make a
pr and say this uh in the setup read me
um but yeah i i believe they work
otherwise just use a printer twenty or
four
cool cool yeah i don't think i've got
anything else yeah i'm very impressed
with this uh yes beautiful isn't it
that's a good idea i haven't seen
non-laggy video on my you can seek
around too and it's fast i can't wait
yeah shout out to dean lee for his
contributions for this
uh i think he's like well past 500
commits now yeah he is oh yeah he's
quite a quite an incredible uh
contributor yeah i mean this is pretty
impressive this is great
wow look at that and i know who's
we're gonna have to give him a comment
this year
oh yeah when are the commies the commies
are coming back oh should we what are
the commies
are coming back
i guess it's always they definitely
always come back right yeah i mean this
is the second year
and everything's a trend right annual
commies uh we've got a lot of annual
things now yeah
and one last we're we're good yeah
everything good cool
final thing just a quick reminder to
everybody
comma threes are in stock if you buy a
comma three it will ship either later
today or uh next week at the latest so
let me put some on the stress test right
there
so check this out
we got a full bin
of ready to ship comma threes a full bin
which is awesome and then
of course we have one terabytes as well
but yeah we have a full bin of 250s
which we've never had before so
production
is killing it cool oh this is the wrong
way
it's so hard to do that reversed
all right
everyone's got oh they went over here
thank you everybody check out the blog
post link in the description to learn
all you need to know
all right
hey
see you guys bye so you got the hack
phone yeah next month
you